the doctor who was leading the
government's efforts to find a corona
virus vaccine says he lost his position
for contradicting the president dr. Rick
bright says he was removed for resisting
a push toward on proven treatments
touted by President Trump but at the
latest White House briefing there was a
public display of unity after these new
tensions between the president and his
medical advisors we shashank reports now
from the White House
it was totally misquoted in the media on
a statement about the fall season and
the virus totally misquoted President
Trump began Wednesday's press briefing
asking the director of the CDC dr.
Robert Redfield to explain comments he
made in an interview to The Washington
Post I didn't say that this was gonna be
worse I said it was gonna be more
complicated field was quoted in the
newspaper saying that a second wave
could be more difficult because it may
coincide with the flu and he eventually
said it was the headline he took issue
with not the article difficult the
President had a much more optimistic
view for the fall it may not come back
at all
we're gonna be watching for it but it's
all possible it's also possible it
doesn't come back at all
moments later dr. Anthony Fauci directly
contradicted that claim we will have
coronavirus in the fall I am convinced
of that
pouchy is one of the few health experts
within the administration who has
publicly disagreed with mr. Trump on
Wednesday a high-ranking scientist said
he was reassigned to another role
because he resisted the White House's
efforts to push chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine as treatments for the
virus Richard bright was the director of
the federal agency in charge of
developing drugs to fight coronavirus
and in a statement bright said the Trump
administration pressured me and other
conscientious scientists to fund
companies with political connections as
well as efforts that lacks scientific
merit the guy says he was pushed out of
a job
maybe was maybe wasn't I did have to hit
the other said I don't know who he is a
spokesperson for Health and Human
Services says it was dr. bright who
recently requested the emergency use of
chloroquine the agency is also under
fire for its secretary Alex Azar's pick
to lead HHS s response to the virus an
aide Brian Harrison who has minimal
public health experience and previously
ran a labradoodle breeding business a
czar defended his choice praising
Harrison's strong leadership during an
unprecedented public health emergency
gale
alright we should thank you